[Musique]
adeline cortesi 25 ans 1 m 78 tu fais
partie des 60 finalistes pour miss
international france cette plaisir oise
originaire de château fort a réussi le
casting en mars dernier au niveau
régional pour participer à ce concours
de beauté créé en 1960
miss international c'est un grand
concours de beauté international qui est
classée 3e concours mondial
après miss univers et miss monde et donc
tous les ans il ya une représentante de
la france qui part à cette élection dont
représenter notre beau pays et bien sûr
si je pouvais ramener une couronne à la
maison ce serait une grande joie pour
essayer de remporter cette couronne
adeline cortesi va tenter de miser sur
son expérience dans le monde de la
beauté
c'est un milieu que j'ai toujours un
petit peu suivi étant plus jeune j'ai
fait un petit peu de mannequinat et
voilà avec les années je me suis dit que
ce serait intéressant de toucher aussi à
ce milieu des miss
j'ai déjà participé à une élection il ya
deux ans et donc cette année j'ai
souhaité réitérer l'expérience
pour ce concours les participants
doivent notamment trouver une tenue
représentant leur région leur
département la miss est aujourd'hui en
séance d'essayage dans cette boutique
versaillaise je vous en ai sélectionné 3
adeline cortesi a choisi de s'inspirer
du xviiie siècle et du château de
versailles
ayant grandi dans un village tout proche
de versailles
j'ai trouvé que c'était un clin d'oeil à
ces sympathiques à mon enfance et donc
j'ai contacté cette jolie boutique
quitterait des costumes versaillais et
donc voilà une de ses robes sera mon
costume régional pour l'élection une
tenue qui pourrait faire la différence
lors de la finale nationale à roubaix le
12 juillet prochain en cas de victoire
adeline s'envolera pour le japon afin de
représenter la france